ils sont là juste avant nous sommes avec
charlie saussez qui sort un double album
live enregistré notamment pas loin d'ici
à coutainville puisque nous sommes chez
lui à blainville sur mer et que voulez
vous que l'on fasse vous dit soyez bien
patient mais pourquoi se voiler la face
je le sais vous de votre monde
la scène c'est là c'est l'axé
authentique là on peut pas tricher sur
la scène quoi donc moi c'est comme ça tu
m'exprime donc il fallait je souhaitais
aussi que pouvoir faire ce cd là
maintenant mais qu'avez vous fait de vos
rêves
devos en ville tout changer quand vous
parliez des qualités
quand vous chantiez la liberté qu'est ce
qui vous a donné la passion de la scène
j'ai toujours eu mais ça a été le bon
moi j'ai rencontré les nids depuis plus
de 40 ans maintenant qu'on a bourlingué
ensemble j'avais envie de dire des
choses et puis bon mais je vais pas je
ne sais pas mais c'est lui qui m'a
poussé à faire de la scène à écrire des
chansons
rina bras et de kits passé
oui
alors quand vous parlez de l'est libyen
sur ces leny escudero et je crois que
sabine et avec charlie saut c'est
justement pour nous parler de son amitié
avec leny escudero avoue sabine oui
jacques donc je suis avec charlie
saussez pour parler de cet album chez
avis haussier sur scène comme on fait le
choix des chansons de lenny je suis très
difficile ce qui l'incriminait
oui non écrit beaucoup oui alors il y en
a qui équipe comme il avoue rennes c'est
incontournable voici celle que je
préfère une petite amourette n'est
jamais trop joli bond on s'est d'abord
ce que dira la vie
les nuls est là et vous c'est vous êtes
à gauche y atteignent presque une
ressemblance mais c'est vrai que c'était
une une très forte amitié pour moi c'est
un réconfort d'avoir eu ce parcours là
et d'avoir été avec lui pour lui et
dernier moment d'ailleurs la campagne et
dernier jour où il a la plume par les
voilà enfin jusqu'au bout avec lui
jusqu'au comme deux frangins très belle
c'est fou tout on a rigolé charlie
saussez le 2 avril au théâtre des
miroirs à cherbourg en cotentin et
maintenant tout autre chose avec demain
soir au cargö birdy nam nam à 20h30
atmar